- I love the cowboy boots!
- I brought a little bit
of Nashville back to you.
- Yes, I love it. I love it.
Meet Awkwafina. Have y'all met before?
- Yes.
- We just did.
I have not, but I'm a big
fan and I love that letter.
I'm a big fan of that letter.
- Oh, thank you.
- And it also kind of blew me
away because the characters
you often play are so full of confidence.
- And bold, yeah.
- And that there's none
of that is in there.
- It's all a facade.
(Kelly laughing)
- Great acting. It's Golden
Globe winning acting.
- Oh wow.
- Do you have stuff like
that? Do you journal?
Do you keep anything and
you find it years later?
- All of my journals end on January 3rd.
(audience laughing)
I would ask for diaries and
then on January 1 I'd nail it.
- [Kelly] Gonna kill it.
- But I have a letter from my wife.
I was up for "Band of Brothers" years ago.
And I got so close on it.
I mean all the way up to, literally,
Steven Spielberg with a handy cam
going along like this
in the rehearsal room.
And for whatever reason I didn't get it.
And it was a hard one.
It sort of was a crusher.
- Oh, when you like really want something.
- She wrote this letter to
me, like, handwritten letter.
And all these years later
when I went to Nashville,
it was just saying, "I know this is hard,
but it's a step and you're gonna
be fine," all these things.
And years later, I'm a pack rat,
so we were moving to
Nashville to do that show.
And I looked in there
and I found this thing
and I was like, "Come
on man, that's perfect."
So somebody writes for me I'm grateful.
- That's so sweet. I love your wife.
I love your whole family.
Your family's so cool.
- Oh, they love you.
My sister loves you so much.
- Oh really?
- I love you, but my sister,
you're not even Kelly Clarkson to her,
you're some Kelly Clarkson to her.
'Cause she says I love
me some Kelly Clarkson.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I see, that must be a southern thing.
Okay, so you've done
well acting in comedies.
So like "The Office", I
know that happened as well.
So how did you end up doing "The Office"?
How did that audition happen?
- "The Office", I've been
doing normal auditions.
I found out how you really get a job
and that is you have tape of you
and one of the cast members on something.
- Like blackmail?
(audience laughing)
- A little bit like blackmail.
Rainn Wilson and I, about seven
or eight years before that,
did a pilot called "The Expendables"
where we played androids
that solved crimes.
And we were, like, robotic but very human.
We spent, I think, a good 30% of it
naked and charging like this.
- Naked and what? (laughs)
- Just shooting above that.
And so when I got there,
I did the whole audition
and one of the producers said,
"So I understand you're
friends with Rainn."
And I said, "Yeah, did
he tell you how we met?"
And he goes, "No." And
I go, "I bet he didn't."
So I told them and they
were losing their minds
trying to picture Rainn being,
and he was amazing in it.
So funny, but we were, like, talking,
"I'm starting to have feelings,"
kind of thing like that.
And I said, "So I have
that, but not only that,
if I get this job day
one, I show up with a DVD
of that pilot that I will give to you."
And I was not even in
my car and my phone rang
and I was like, "Oh, I got the job."
So, yeah, that's how I got on.
- Note to self, actors.
(audience applauding)
Note to self.
Well, Awkwafina, what was
your most memorable audition?
Good or bad.
- In the early days I went to a thing
where the reader definitely
passed wind during,
while I was speaking, and I was,
and I didn't know how to, like, end it.
I was like, "Did you just hear that?"
And they were like,
"No, I didn't hear that.
Did you hear something?"
And I was like, but it's
gonna be on the tape that you,
okay, forget it, forget it."
- So it's gonna look like
you are ripping one. (laughs)
- It looks like I did it.
It looks like I had done it
and I didn't stop it
and it just kept going.
- That was your first acting test,
acting like that didn't happen.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, exactly.
- Oh my God.
Okay, so Charles, your latest
project is "Outer Banks."
So what's happening this season?
(audience cheering)
- It's been so great.
It's been a really great
season for my character.
'Cause he's sort of won all the gold
and all the treasure at
the end of last season
but he really didn't have anything.
Meanwhile the pogues
have nothing, these kids.
But they have each other.
So I sort of hit a rock
bottom and then it's like,
what's gonna happen to the character next?
But the thing I love most is we shot
so much of it under lockdown,
you know, the quarantining and all that.
And so these kids that,
these younger actors, they're not kids,
but they're so great and
they're so wonderful.
They sort of blew up under,
you know, the lockdowns.
- In the bubble.
- Yeah, exactly.
And then they were wearing
their masks and so,
but since then, it was really nice.
We just had the premiere, had an event
with bands onstage and
everything to get to see them
get all the love from
everybody, it's a thrill.
And people seem to be
loving "Outer Banks" three.
- I love that.
People getting their
flowers while they're alive.
That's nice.
- Yeah, exactly.
They deserve it too. They're so cool.
- Yeah, I love that.
Well, you're playing your
new song for us later.
So it's called, "One Good Move."
So what's it about other than,
you know, a solid good move?
(audience laughing)
- No, it's not that. It's about my wife.
I was talking with some
songwriters, young songwriters,
and saying I don't envy them,
because, you know, phones
that have video cameras.
Thank God they weren't
around when I was young.
'Cause I was a moron when I was a kid.
I was a bad decision machine.
You put in a quarter, I will
give you a bad decision.
(audience laughing)
And then I said, "You know
what? Except for one thing.
Somehow that idiot met her and somehow
was smart enough to hang on to her."
And I go, "She was my one good move."
So when it was time to write
they go, "So that's the title."
And I went, "Ooh, yeah, you're right."
It's actually her birthday today.
- It is?
- So I get to sing "One Good Move"
for my one good move on her birthday.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] What is your
life? That is so sweet.
- [Charles] Right, what is it?
- Okay, we need another break, everybody.
Charles's new song is
called "One Good Move."
And stick around because he's
performing it a little later.
It's gonna be awesome.